I want to talk a little bit about the
flooding going on in Louisiana Red Cross
is calling this the nation's worst
disaster since superstorm sandy we have
had double digits number of people
killed 40,000 homes affected 30,000
people rescued this is being described
as the worst flooding to hit the state
of Louisiana by some although I don't
know if there is a complete scientific
or meteorological consensus on that
about 8,000 people remain in emergency
shelters and most of Louisiana has
received at least a foot of rain since
the beginning of this past weekend some
places getting as much as 30 inches of
rain
Roland Spano junior who's been a member
for nearly a year reached out to me and
sent me video and pictures that he took
in Louisiana of the stating flooding the
first is a video that I'll show you and
sort of describe for you here which is
actually Roland in a boat and you can
see the water level almost as high as
street signs you can see only the tops
of trees the water seems absolutely
filthy which often happens when
floodwaters come in really really really
horrible stuff and then also a couple of
pictures to show you that roll and took
houses I mean half covered by water
amazing we have one other picture to
show you here out of a this seems to be
a parking lot where you see cars half
covered by water and and and this is
just absolutely disastrous and Roland
actually told me that he was involved in
a rescue here and that he was in the
last truck out when rescuing his cousin
and her husband a lot of people have
what some would describe sort of like as
an irrational fear of flooding even
living in parts of the country where
flooding isn't likely this stuff is the
stuff of nightmares though yeah
and it's amazing the places that it can
happen yeah not a surprise on the
Louisiana coast no no not at all but as
as sea levels rise and the weather
changes and we get more and more storms
every year
you got to start thinking about possibly
avoiding the coast this is a climate
change story right climate change is not
individual weather events one flood one
record warm day one record cold day
we've said time and again we don't want
to confuse individual weather events
with climate but when we talk about
climate change we are talking about sea
level rise we're talking about the
possibility of coastal areas being
permanently under water as a result of
sea level rise along with patterns of
continued record warm days which we've
seen and I'll tell you about again in a
second record cold days flooding in
areas that typically don't have it or
more often than they typically have it
or more inches of rain than they would
typically have as far as this individual
weather event it was caused by number
one huge downpours of rain that are part
of what the National Weather Service is
calling an inland sheared tropical
depression happening at the same time as
nearly record high moisture content in
the air so again we want to distinguish
between weather versus climate Louis but
we also want to think about how climate
change will influence longer term
frequency of certain types of weather
events erratic weather this type of
event yes it's um it's it's very scary
but it's happening and just to be aware
of it and if you live on the coast or in
one of these areas don't go without
flood insurance I read that in some of
these towns one two percent of the
population of the properties were
protected by flood insurance and I get
it right I mean I have a friend who
lives on a floodplain in western
Massachusetts his insurance would have
been a thousand dollars for the year had
he been just slightly out of that
floodplain being in the floodplain it
went up to $7,000 for the years some
people think oh you just get the flood
insurance premium it's not like an extra
hundred bucks for the year I mean it's a
huge huge price difference so I get not
being able to afford that or opting
against it and then unfortunately these
are the situations we have where most of
those affected did not have flood
insurance and it's absolutely horrible
Gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
SiC games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3
Wii and a bunch of other platforms and
you can play as many games as you want
for one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low used price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s